In this segment, we discuss
splitting a Poisson process
into two different streams.
So we have a Poisson process
with some arrival rate lambda,
and whenever there
is an arrival,
we decide to send it either
to one or another stream.
And for example, this arrival
might be sent to that stream,
this arrival might be
sent to this stream,
that arrival might be
sent to that stream.
How do we decide where
to send these arrivals?
We make those decisions
using independent coin
flips with a coin that has a
certain fixed bias equal to q.
So when this arrival
comes, there's
probability q that it will
be sent that direction
or probability 1
minus q that it will
be sent in the other direction.
All of these coin
flips are independent,
so the decision on where
to send the second arrival
is going to be independent
from the decision of where
to send the first arrival.
And furthermore, we
make one more assumption
that these coin flips are
independent from everything
else.
They're independent
from the time history
of the original Poisson process.
For example, the coin flip
that decides the destination
of this first arrival
can not depend
on how long it took for
this arrival to occur.
We will argue now that this
stream is a Poisson process
and by symmetry,
therefore, this stream
is also a Poisson process.
We need to verify
two assumptions.
One has to do with independence.
The argument here is entirely
analogous to arguments
that we have already
carried out in the past,
namely disjoint time intervals
in the original process
are independent.
Coin flips that happened during
those disjoint time intervals
are also independent
of each other,
and for this reason, whatever
happens during disjoint time
intervals in that stream
will also be independent.
The other property
that we need to verify
has to do with probabilities
of small intervals.
If we take a little interval
here of length delta,
what is going to happen
during that interval?
Well, we look at what happens
during the corresponding
interval in the original stream.
In the original
stream, the probability
of having two or more arrivals--
this probability is order
of delta squared,
so there's no way
of having two or more arrivals
during that little interval,
or to be more precise,
the probability
of two or more arrivals here
is going to be negligible,
order of delta squared.
What is the probability
of having one arrival
during that little interval?
We will have one
arrival here if we've
had one arrival in this
time interval, which
happens with probability
lambda times delta,
and also the coin
flip sent the arrival
in this direction,
which is something
that happens with probability
q, and the remaining probability
is assigned to the
event of having
zero arrivals during
that interval.
So the probability of two or
more arrivals is negligible,
and the probability
of one arrival
is proportional to delta.
And that's what we need in
order to have a Poisson process.
The factor of proportionality
that multiplies delta
is equal to lambda times q.
Therefore, this is a Poisson
process with parameter,
or arrival rate, equal
to lambda times q.
And by a similar argument,
this process here
is going to be a Poisson
process with parameter
equal to lambda times 1 minus q.
So by splitting a Poisson
process using independent coin
flips, we obtain two
different Poisson streams.
Are these Poisson
streams independent?
For the case of the
Bernoulli process,
we had seen that the resulting
streams were not independent.
The reason for the
Bernoulli process
was that if I tell you
that at a certain slot
we had an arrival
in this stream,
that would tell you that
in the corresponding time
slot of the other process
you could not have an arrival
and that was a
source of dependence.
It turns out that for
the Poisson process,
because it runs in
continuous time,
telling you that we had an
arrival at this particular time
instant does not give you
any substantial or any
nontrivial information
about the other process,
and the two processes
remain independent.
This result is surprising in
some ways, but it is true.
A mathematical
derivation proceeds
along a line that's a little
different from the intuitive
argument that I just outlined.
And we will not go
through that derivation,
but it's a useful fact to know.